also his wider mandate we also were
lucky enough to hear from president
zielinski directly and I can tell you
that we raised over 4 million pounds in
additional contributions and a whole
range of non-financial technical support
for the work of the ICC from uh disaster
victim identification experts and the
Danish have offered through to forensic
experts from the our Dutch friends and
the belgians and the Czechs the list of
support that we provided investigative
support but also support with Witnesses
and as well as that
there is a an interesting
offer from Ghana for a relocation
agreement for victims and Witnesses and
a whole range that's just a sense of
some of the highlights but given the
indictment of President
Putin on Friday I think it was really
important that we matched our words with
deeds and show the Practical sport to
give effect to the icc's Mandate so that
just gives you a flavor of what we
discussed today dealing over to you if
there's anything else you'd like to add
I think that covers it all I would just
like to thank you
to be here with so many countries and
just again focusing on
a core issue of today and how do we
prevent impurity and how do we help
victims so thank you again and I think
great well um I open to questions if we
got David from the BBC here David
thank you very much David Wallace locker
from the BBC Mr Robb what can the UK do
to ensure that Vladimir Putin faces
Justice but I think there's a number of
things first of all I think hosting this
event uh just a few days fortuitously
after that indictment bringing countries
together we've always said our vision of
global greatness is a Force for good in
the world using our soft power our
convenient power of course we do it with
our Dutch friends who host the
international criminal court I think
that's very powerful having over 40
countries come here and pledge New
Practical support which is the kind of
nuts and Bubbles that are a criminal
court an international criminal court
needs to do the job remember it's stuck
out there in The Hague as a court but
you think of all the other wrap around
support that any justice system would
have from investigators to witness
relocation that's the kind of practical
things that we can do and if you're
asking
um
can Putin will Putin inevitably sitted
out well I remember as a young war
crimes lawyer in The Hague in 2004
negotiating a sentence enforcement
agreement with the UN for the Yugoslavia
tribunal and 17 late years later
Carriage ended up in a jail at British
jail as a result of it Charles Taylor
ended up in jail but also which was
brought to trial so I think we've got
Justice on our side and I think we've
got history on our side but we'll need
to be patient
and can we take a question from Marie
from AFP
bound additional support that you talked
about where do I come from which
countries thank you
I think with you are keeping a the Dutch
of course uh the Dutch in the UK put in
but um there are two or three different
areas for the support I I didn't I was
keeping an overall tally I didn't have
the full breakdown but I would say that
actually quite a few countries put in
what they can of course there's the
regular budget the ICC needs to be
funded on a regular basis but actually
particularly given the workload involved
in Ukraine I think it's right that those
of us that can step up with some extra
support do you remember any of the
others no well you know everybody did
what they could so that's on the one
hand giving expertise sending people
over from the military from the police
from
different areas because it's very
important that we ensure that we have
the evidence that's uh that's right now
in the Ukraine and of course a few of
the countries also said we have
additional funds and that will go on the
one hand to the diversity fund and on
the other hand to
um
supporting victims in Ukraine to you
know do their stories and make sure that
they are not re-traumatized while giving
their story while doing a story and but
at the same time they get the help they
need but also it will allow the experts
to gather the evidence they need from
them so I think the funds will go to
those two pillars and different
countries contributed
um okay we're given we have our Dutch
co-host can I take a question from ANP
I'll come back to you
is it yeah
you recognize yes I recognize them
how good will this money do for the
people in Ukraine in the coming years
well um I think the most important thing
is that this will help ukrainians to
achieve Justice because we know that
there's a world going on right now and
every day if we would wait for Gathering
the evidence we would lose we would lose
important proof and evidence so there is
no time to lose I think that are coming
from Ireland said we have to add now and
there is no time to waste and that is
also what ukrainians want from us and I
think they are very right to ask that
also from us so this will help
everything together will help to give
and bring ukrainians Justice
can I also um take one from NHK and is
it Mayu Oishi because it was important
for us to have uh not just Japan but
also Asian representation here at this
conference I don't know whether we've
got please
what do you think the importance of
Japanese support as a host country of G7
what do you think did
cleanse of Japanese support to ICC as a
host country of G7
uh well I think it's incredibly
important
um both for Japan's record of being a
very strong supporter of the ICC I
remember when I was a foreign office
lawyer between 2000 and three and six
based in hey uh the there was a Japanese
judge seconded their superb and actually
providing that concrete support for the
work of the court is incredibly
important but I also think from a
diplomatic point of view providing an
anchor into Asia and showing and taking
a lead from the Asian point of view is
also very important because we still
need to expand the support for the ICC
um it can't just be a European or a a a
Euro Atlantic supported court so I think
in both ways I think it was really
important you know I don't know whether
you were down no totally agree with the
Japanese
it is very very important so I was very
glad to see our Japanese colleague here
and he also made remarks to the meeting
of course this summer where hopefully
they can pick up what we started here
uh Patrick and then I'll come to do we
have NBC here as well I wanted to
um yes great okay fine can I do it sorry
uh Patrick which I work for the guardian
um I wanted to ask you what particularly
the British position on this idea of a
special tribunal to try the crime of
aggression and the leadership crime do
you accept there is a gap in the law and
that it needs to be filled and how would
you like to fill it and lastly on the
issue of double standards the Chinese
today have been saying the West is
supplying double standards uh and here
we are on the anniversary of the
invasion of Iraq where nobody has been
uh any Tribune or Court
and I believe it was illegal well
actually I when I was based in The Hague
the ICC did conduct a preliminary
examination into the invasion of Iraq
and decided for various reasons not
least because of the accountability we
have domestically that there was no case
for proceeding further and that's why
you have an international court so that
you can objectively independently and
partially look at these things and come
to a view in relation to your first
question which was around
aggression look there was I mean
principally this meeting was about the
nuts and bolts support for the ICC to do
its job but of course we had the
Ukrainian prosecutor General and there's
much discussion about this I don't think
it's so much a gap in the law it's a
more question of jurisdiction and we'll
keep working together uh to consider it
but I think right now uh the uh the
priority certainly at this conference
has been to try and give the ICC the
Practical support to deliver its mandate
the British government then doesn't yet
have a position
now we're engaged with uh I know you're
engaged but you do have a position
well to be honest with you the the
discussions are still a relatively
preliminary stage we understand the
importance of it to the people of
Ukraine and president zielinski and we
want to transport them as best we can
and I think it's certainly true to say
that the
um president zielinski the overriding
crime above all others has been the
invasion in the question of aggression
and we want to try and deal with that
support in as best we can but it is a
much more complicated question to deal
with
let me give the last word to Max Taylor
and uh MVC
thank you very much Mr Rob
um just wanted to say there's a there's
another big meeting obviously going on
today
um in Moscow um with the president XI
meeting with President Putin
um the Chinese are not members of the
ICC
um but what kind of role could you see
China playing in achieving Justice in
Ukraine and particularly these issues
that have been raised by the ICC
um well first of all by the way it was
excellent to have Bruce Schwartz from
the Department of Justice here joining
us and to update us on the U.S position
I think that was a really welcome by
everyone uh here at the conference in
relation to the Chinese position I I
want to
set expectations too high if I can put
it like that but I think the one thing
that China is a member of the public
member of the security Council leading
member of the International Community
can and should do is say that the
Cardinal rules of international law
including the right not to have your
country invaded unlawfully or to be
adhered to and I think the extent to
which he can whether it's private
vehicle or publicly apply diplomatic
pressure and leverage that effect to
that extent will be welcome
and thanks again to our uh our Dutch
friends for co-hosting with us and
thanks thanks again thank you so much
thank you